[Music]
there's nothing in there
the eight news now i-team investigating
startling allegations of fraud millions
of your tax dollars reportedly stolen as
part of what federal authorities say was
a fake business yeah that money was
supposed to help struggling small
businesses instead the irs says it
fueled a local man's lavish lifestyle
the i-team's david charns went to the
address this man said he was working
from david how much money are we talking
about we're talking about 11 million of
your tax dollars that's according to
court documents going to buy a tesla
bentley and properties across the valley
this sponsored web article on ink
magazine called him a dreamer you see it
down there someone who quote built a
thriving flooring business out of the
ashes the i-team went to the business
this man said he was working at him
trying to get some answers we did not
see anything thriving
11.2 million dollars it's how much money
federal investigators allege 28 year old
milades fully stole in fraudulent ppp
loans the money meant to help small
businesses stay afloat during the
pandemic instead according to criminal
documents from irs investigators it went
toward houses cars and investments
court documents say applications for
those loans were written out of this
office on east sunset near reed airport
there's nothing in there there was no
sign of any business when we visited
when dez fully applied for his first
loan for a business called best floors
investigators say he told the government
he needed money to cover 76 employees
but the irs says des fully really only
had one the i-team finding the nevada
state contractor's board cited best
floors and des fuli in may 2020 a month
after the irs says he filed for the
fraudulent loans according to court
documents in another application des
fully reported to have nearly 500
employees for another business but in
reality investigators say he had none
in that business reportedly run out of
the place we just showed you des fully
has pleaded not guilty and his public
defender declined to comment irs
criminal investigators continue to go
after suspects and they say they have
found about 2 billion dollars in cobit
fraud money so far we have a phone
number to make a report on 8newsnow.com
i'm david charns live local now